hey guys max today I will be testing out
how this nearly $15,000 Mac Pro does in
gaming both a Mac OS and in windows
using bootcamp I will also be doing a
couple benchmarks just to see where this
Vanka to graphics card with 32 gigabytes
of HBM to memory falls in line compared
to other graphics cards and also seeing
how loud does the system get because it
is literally just inches away from my
ear sitting on the desk here so let's
jump right into it right now we are in
Mac OS and I have four denied install
that's the first game I'm gonna test and
we'll see how it performs Mac OS and
then we'll flip over to Windows so for
and I chose some default settings for us
we have full screen 1440p 3d resolution
is only at 75% and everything set to
high settings not ultra oh that was
close no no no I thought I was safe
there sorry max everything out that we
can we really need to find a gun here
and as you guys could tell I'm not
really that skilled of a fortnight
player but we are playing at above 100
frames per second think we have to jump
up to 4k so won't let me set to 4k I
have to go higher than 4k here but that
is fine yeah we got a sniper rifle as
you guys might be able to see we're
playing at right about 60 fps 55 to 65
this is playing out about 4.5 K higher
than 4k with all the options maxed out
that it allowed me to max out here in
Mac OS oh glitch no please there's a guy
here don't do this to me I'm not sure
why that crash maybe it was just the
Wi-Fi or Internet cutouts but of course
for tonight does not run as well in Mac
OS as it does in Windows so before we go
into bucum and check out how it runs
there let me give a huge thank you to
our sponsor Micro Center for making our
Mac Pro content possible Micra Center
has 25 stores nationwide with an
impressive variety of electronics from
gaming VR computer parts like processors
graphics and everything else needed to
build or upgrade a PC or Mac Micra
Center has been an Apple authorized
dealer since 1980 they have a dedicated
Apple Department with highly
Apple sales associates aside from the
iPhone Micra Center carries the full
lineup of Apple products and they have
the largest selection of third-party
products for Mac and iPad come into a
local Micro Center today and talk to one
of their Apple experts to order the
specific Mac Pro configuration that best
suits your needs check the link in the
description to find a local micro Center
near you or to browse all of their Apple
products we are here in Windows using
bootcamp and I ran the unit in heav'n
benchmark and instead of getting about a
hundred and twelve frames per second Mac
OS we're getting one hundred thirty
eight point six so that is a really good
improvement in graphics gaming
performance just going into Windows so
it looks like for tonight and Windows
defaulted to much higher settings we're
locked in out 4k resolution everything's
maxed out so this seems good let's test
it out yeah well as you guys could see
we're getting an extremely consistent 52
55 FPS a little bit of hit 60 but it's
ticking right there at 52 to 55 and I'm
really surprised by how consistent it is
which if you know Mac systems that is
very impressive from what I could see
even playing at 4k with everything you
maxed out you can get usable frame rates
without any performance issues
whatsoever or drop it down to medium and
you can play at you know 100 hundred 20
whatever you guys want to play at now I
have Forza horizon four open here on PC
and I'm running the benchmark I'm not
sure what the resolution is set to but
the actual monitor in Windows is playing
back at 5k and it's right now it's
locked at 60fps and it looks like the
graphics card is only running at 40
percent you saw drop down to 39 38 41 so
it is having no issues of course Forza
looks beautiful and it's really well
optimized so that was at 1080p using the
ultra preset in the FPS average was 146
but that's not what I'm interested in I
want the best graphics so let's click
this box right here playing at five
hey resolution okay that looks nice this
I see no aliasing the graphics look
amazing at 5k ultra preset and graphics
card usage is now 98% and looks like
we're staying above 60fps I unlocked it
60 59 61 62 63 at 5k ultra and it looks
gorgeous
not bad oh look how consistent that
framerate is 5k ultra preset averaging
50 8.7 frames per second keep in mind 5k
is about double the amount of resolution
than forking not a little bit more
double and now for my favorite game
modern warfare and this is playing back
a 4k resolution mix of high settings
with some of the effects turned down not
bad I think I'm gonna kick some of these
graphics settings up or maybe even try
5k now unfortunately we are getting this
artifacting we saw with the 16 inch
MacBook Pro we just got new drivers for
that and even people with Nvidia
graphics cards had this issue one thing
I want to mention is that the Mac Pro
has basically been silent this whole
time when playing in Mac OS and in
Windows and using all those benchmarks
and it's sitting here right next to me
here so I just maxed out all of the
graphics in 4k everything is set to the
highest settings
stop her anyway from me haha so it looks
like even if I maxed out all the
settings it didn't really make a
difference our FPS is higher because
we're in a smaller environment here but
I'm still playing a 6070 sometimes 80
FPS 4k max out all the settings now
these artifacts are kind of annoying but
I don't think they're changing anything
as far as frame rates now the final test
5k resolution yep it's lagging we're at
40 frames per second 5k resolution
everything is maxed out right now very
consistent though 39-41 I would not
recommend playing at 5k of course if we
go to ground war I'm guessing we're
gonna be playing at about 30 FPS and I'm
not a fan of doing that now I know a lot
of you guys like to play a 1440p with
high refresh rate monitors so here's
1440p everything maxed out
we are playing at about 91/2 110 frames
per second here depending on what we're
doing about a hundred No
why did I exit out what's going they
almost had an idea so a modernwarfare
it's not reading out the GPU temperature
unfortunately but I opened up gpu-z here
it looks like the graphics card is
running at 67 degrees Celsius with
everything maxed out yeah if you guys
don't know about bootcamp drivers
dot-com you can actually get actual AMD
drivers for Windows that they'll release
there and the performance simply gets
better with those drivers so hopefully
this artifacting will go away after the
drivers have been updated but even on
the first drivers our performance is
excellent so now we are running fire
strike to test out how the system
compares to other graphics cards
processors not recognize graphics card
is not recognized on the graphics driver
is not approved so I'm not really sure
what if that's gonna affect it or not
but it looks like our graphics core is
twenty six thousand eight hundred fifty
as you guys saw in actual gaming
performance and performed really well
and keep in mind this is the first
version of the drivers and with boot
camp I had no issues so it looks like
the Vega 2 is actually on the charts now
and the score is basically identical to
the r-tx 2080 here and just slightly
behind that the 2080 super so you know
that for that price is that performance
amazing well not really because you can
build a PC for about two thousand
dollars is gonna perform the same and
please don't buy this Mac Pro for gaming
but as a Mac this is really great
performance is the best performance
we've ever had by far and this system is
almost 15,000 but you don't need to get
192 gigs of ram or a terabyte SSD or an
afterburner card or a 12 core processor
you could just get the base and upgrade
the graphics card or upgrade it yourself
to 5700 XT it's gonna work just fine
you'll get
performance close to it and keep in mind
the drivers will be up to you'll
actually gonna get a little bit more
performance out of it so overall I am
happy you can game at 4k with new games
with all the settings maxed out and even
a 5 or 6 K if you drop down some of
those settings so it's gonna look
fantastic so after work is done you can
play some games with great results good
consistent frame rates in silent
performance so Apple we now have a
gaming PC so thank you guys for watching
let me know any questions or comments
down in the comments section and below
once again we have links in the video
description you guys can click above to
subscribe and we will see you guys in
the next video
[Music]